even in the context of a series that
regularly receives criticism for feeling
formulaic pokemon brilliant diamond and
shining pearl are particularly familiar
as remakes of the 4th gen titles diamond
and pearl these are homages to an era of
pokemon when the series was just
starting to settle into a comfortable
niche not only that but these are
extremely faithful remakes right down to
the visual style and classic combat
mechanics that makes the experience feel
downright homey if not a little deja vu
inducing
[Music]
diamond and pearl and therefore
brilliant diamond and shining pearl are
from a simpler era of pokemon before
full 3d became the norm instead they
hearkened back to the series roots as an
overhead sprite based rpg there would be
clear delineation between a grass tile
and a town tile and you would move from
one to the other as if on a checkerboard
you can see some of those roots at work
in the remakes too while your character
has a full range of movement in the
world and the geometry isn't terribly
blocky there are some obvious
anachronisms how npcs always move at
right angles for example or how floor
tiles or size to fit your character
perfectly it's only mildly distracting
and for the most part it's just charming
equally charming is the art style itself
especially in the overworld while the
more recent sword and shield have
adopted a more live elongated style that
looks similar to the various pokemon
animated series brilliant diamond and
shining pearl have translated the squat
pixel art of the originals into an
equally squat and adorable animated
chibi style your character looks
appropriately retro while simply
exploring in the tall grass or walking
around town but the style looks
especially great when the camera zooms
in closer during dialogue sequences at
those points the artwork really shines
because you get to see the depth and
vibrancy of the characters they almost
look like living vinyl dolls
[Music]
similarly many of the pokemon themselves
benefit from this new art style
especially the designs that are more
elegant and simple like the pleasantly
plump starly some of the more complex
designs suffer for it though since the
little flourishes can look awkward
that's a problem when you're going to be
spending a significant amount of time
looking at monferno's red outline butt
but otherwise it isn't too distracting
your own characters and npcs also change
from their squat chibi forms into more
sword and shield-like models during
battles and those look perfectly fine
even if they have less personality on
top of the visual distinctions these
remakes pack some quality of life tweaks
from later games that make it easier to
go back to this generation borrowing a
page from sword and shield experience
share is on by default and distributes
experience across all pokemon currently
in your party which makes grinding out
levels less of a chore likewise
acquiring hidden moves provides you with
permanent access to them regardless of
who's in your party which will
automatically take care of navigation
tasks like breaking rocks or surfing
through water without needing to keep a
dummy pokemon on hand and you can access
your pokemon boxes from anywhere rather
than needing to head back into town and
check in at a pokemon center you can
have a pokemon of choice follow you as
well once you've progressed which adds a
nice sense of personality to your
friendship with the little pocket
monsters the other major addition is the
grand underground a revision of the
original underground mechanic that
borrows some elements from more recent
games you can see pokemon roaming freely
and some pokemon can only be caught by
exploring here similar to the wild areas
in sword and shield the change doesn't
feel massive but it does seem primed to
add longevity to the end game once
players have fought through all the gems
and bested the elite four so far pokemon
brilliant diamond and shining pearl keep
enough classic elements to feel like a
comfy nostalgia trip while smoothing
over enough of the rough edges that they
feel relatively contemporary with other
recent pokemon games it can't be easy
for a storied franchise to pay homage to
its legacy while also modernizing it in
this way but in my experience so far
brilliant diamond and shining pearl
strike the right balance
[Music]
me
[Music]